I feel so you're going on give me I will
that's gonna be the best part I need to
go I need to go viral we're gonna zoom
in on his toes
[Music]
it's a
yeah
I told you this was the last Monday
morning in her life
I was more than happy to take the snarky
comments along of self-promotion like
that's cute I'm like but business is
real you know your opinions lovely and
then what's great is and this is why I'm
we can't waver from it is a lot of the
[ __ ] that I said became true because I'm
tripling down on the one thing I've had
I've always had that intuitive as a as a
13th as a 16 year old I just sold my
entire baseball card collection at the
height of baseball cards and convert it
into comic books because I could taste
the ship and it happened and so then
that that's how I built my business I
built Wine Library on the back of
Australian and Spanish and New Zealand
wines while sherry Lehman's and Zaki's
and morels were playing France in
California so like it's always been
there and it will always be there and
that's always you know what we do I've
been in this business a long time
the only about me have been in theme
parks TV internet you've been in movies
but I always the same
business-to-consumer attention all you
do is tension to the consumer don't get
distracted by technology don't get
subscribe to the same game housed in
Zoomer my angel
what is this overdoing I'm eating my own
dog food like like I know how it plays
out its leverage I want the next Mark
Zuckerberg to come to me and say I'm
cool and be on the board like this is
people are misunderstanding what's
happening and that's how I think about
stuff like when everybody debates all
this stuff all you need to do is build
brand with the end consumer I mean
always always brands win two things when
brands winning that's right if you can
figure out how to make my life easier
whatever that product is you know do
rocks laughing I mean so I had a feeling
like it just it's very obvious for me to
see who's navigated careers or who's
emerging to navigate careers and by the
way I actually don't care about anything
else than those two things speed is how
I correlate convenience you know and
that's why ads are bad ads are taking
people's time away in a world where
people now care about time so much which
is why native matters to me so much
because you're integrating within the
content
and radio is so separate at one of our
corporate values is urgency wins we
start everything when somebody says
we're going to build some we start hey
let's do 24 hours
we make them justify why we take 3
months to do it but as opposed to trying
to pull people in start with 24 hours
everything can be done 24 hours and
unless you have the amount of money that
our potential clients are wasting in a
20-17 world is extraordinary and it's
being poured in two places television
commercials and traditional programmatic
digital inventory to buy programmatic on
a banner or a pre-roll where you don't
know where it's actually being deployed
and the KPI is the CPM and the creative
has no idea contextually where it's
sitting is insanity I just want to have
that in the back your mind as well all
right good to see you against us right
just get some light for him hey guys
it's a to 10:00 p.m.
d-roc overslept I'm kidding lower the
strategy I should have been recording a
little bit in film but little late start
super fun meeting any time you get to go
with the Titans of media so he's a lot
of fun but um just trucking along super
productive CES just a ton of business
meetings a lot of people excited but the
pure wild deal asking about that but
just a lot of biz dev some really
successful meetings with our Facebook
and good to see snapchatting and just a
lot of clients and media companies and
started really again in the game it's
reminding me very much to when Wine
Library kind of hit a crescendo moment
probably about two thousand three and
four where the other people in the game
started giving you that head nod like
hey we know you're in it
is a very big industry these are
billions and billions of dollars worth
companies so took a little time even
though I started from a nice space but I
could taste it and it's exciting I love
the game I respect everybody even our
competitors people that don't believe in
us but I want to win I want to win more
than anything I get a picture in the
shore of course oh man I cannot believe
this as my favorite
you see this murder you just made my
shift just made all of this worth it man
Renzo oh my god I'm late I'm Way too
excited about this man thank you man
yeah I've been this with you I have my
best friend Louise he's working at the
Cosmopolitan and he said hey man like
you got to listen to this guy man you
guys cuz I seen my friend he was
hustling the hustling I was like you
know I like what you're doing it you're
getting it and he was like you don't
understand like you gotta listen to this
guy he's a monster man like he's gonna
turn your life around
thank you said I want you to listen to
this and then ever since man it's just
be like tough guys crazy Gary oh my god
I'm just gonna let me the fingers pick
it up yeah no problem man and you know
he uh he said here bring your medius
here and I was like no way I was like
you're gonna see him and he said Gary
wasn't here at the end of the day tough
and I was like and then I was like dude
you put on my snapchat yeah yeah
oh man this is awesome brother
Asura filling it so much we appreciate
appreciate what to do no worries how are
you doing you're so right let me just
don't think about this our music you
were talking about like oh - yeah hi all
about motivation
we couldn't victory of course thank you
thank you man
pretty fun oh you got California humans
poll and like you posted it but you did
this video like years ago and you
predicted about this music industry
about monumentally I'm making peace
right now and you couldn't be more right
thank you back good luck is you can have
you good luck take it how you doing good
man what's going on right nice legs
going good yeah what's uh what you want
to walk and talk a little bit well I got
to my next thing right we're in REO
right now so let's get the cosmos all
right let's go this way right yeah but
we won't
dirac don't fill this he's talking about
important [ __ ] all right I mean you
could film the like say image not the
audience
whatever I'm gonna give you a real good
piece of ice I came into the game five
years ago and was already rich
successful and a guy and I didn't care I
didn't keep the work and the fact like
chip at it one way that I don't get
crippled like everybody woman right like
I let it comfortable yeah
when it comes to you you [ __ ] language
you know what I mean yeah so so you're
young and hungry even want to [ __ ]
rip people skulls I want out of their
bodies but let this [ __ ] come to you
here's what I know I know that actions
yeah we didn't walk in a circle no we
did not know weed in that line Kosmos
over there no we did not
oh that's amazing so mad we walked in a
circle no we did not
yeah right there holy [ __ ] regular music
problems but what I have what the reason
why I think is interesting I was invited
by son
[Music]
yeah tickets elevator no one's producing
high quality content as rapidly as fast
as motivational and actually I meant to
your live the other day I was like let
me show the carry spare you're like you
like yo kicks I got crazy look up the
hashtag Parma for 47 hours and I was
like okay dude you know it's like I'm
trying to help
I mean it's which is good right ask you
you know what it feels like to have
somebody call you and say they're a
single email you and say they're single
mom and they made 200 bucks selling eBay
[ __ ] today you're gonna cheat and it
means something to them yeah I mean
that's the thing I do the rare break the
world of is 90% of the world are there
Freight and they want to be safe and and
that's okay and everyone they don't have
to be like I wanted understand your zone
yep then 5% of the world they're
entrepreneurial but they're doing it
with the ego and perception that's
driving and it's not true correct it is
5%
I sit in you sit in that designing life
it's design life by design everything I
do is because I want to there's no ego
there no perception little [ __ ] it's
because this is what's making me happy
and what's feeling just like longer
prison I love it section I Love You Man
let's keep this conversation going yeah
I'll see you New York
hey thank you very much thank you what's
your name
Ryan hey Brian Horace very nice man no
pleasure thanks brother thank you miss
welcome
[Music]
hey we're out of our room and the rock
trying to get me to do the update from
one year ago I'm just I'm just recording
this vertically just because I know what
about to say and I just want document
like it's so obvious to me what's gonna
happen a levy in snapchat like our
execution these next 12 months it's
gonna be it's gonna be so [ __ ] crazy
what it all looks like a year from today
like maybe you'll use this video to show
the numbers as a matter of fact make
sure you document my YouTube subscribers
and my snails say right now a snapchat
story how many stories that movie knows
I'm getting and will literally run this
video put in your calendar right now a
year from today we will put put this out
because what a lot of people understand
is its execution and we put the pieces
in place a full execution right yep but
the truth is I'm not worried about how
many more followers I have on Instagram
or snapchat or Facebook and it's
phenomenally great it's the impact it's
the fact that you can't walk [ __ ]
seven steps d-roc without somebody
saying hey you're not hey like it's
pretty cool what like you've done for my
life or this and that like it when I
said and you can clip it here like in a
year from now is it's me so [ __ ]
crazy it's going to be not how many
[ __ ] followers I have it's how much
impact I'm having in helping others do
their thing because I'm gonna get mine
I'm gonna win regardless I was a
business man that won and made millions
before livers to [ __ ] documenting of
Internet's and blogs and things that
nature I'm building an agency Gary B's
my side how so I'm doing this for legacy
it's brand building gives me leverage
for other opportunities but the ROI is
the tweets go search my username right
now and go look at all the people that
miraculously have a better life
overnight because they're actually
selling [ __ ] that's readily in their
house then I have 500 bucks to go do
that thing it's impact it's how many
[ __ ] follow I don't even update on my
followers Darach what do you mean it's
the worst where were you by the way I
have a funny feeling your keys not gonna
work why is your gonna keep why is your
key gonna work in mine's not
please God yeah forgot my joke
I forgot my gel in [ __ ] New Orleans
just forgot my [ __ ] I have it's right
on in you gel like you can't get around
here you know so we're probably going to
want to do a new front
you should probably you telling you
you'll help him with his if he gives us
an artist they're coming to ours
nobody knew something else we're gonna
do a [ __ ] up front but and like break
the whole thing we're gonna do it
wouldn't that we're gonna do it we're
gonna do a uh back front
we you shouldn't commit your money
upfront like a [ __ ] idiot we're gonna
[ __ ] just like you know what I mean
like we got a blank everything now uh
we're gonna ng that you did cancel it
we're here this is faster Kichler
you got a three or five or two or one
year player okay you gotta do rock yeah
thank you yes sir she vows she really
wants to build your brand like that
everybody does
that's smart yeah see I'm nervous about
it all right
can we make 2017 a year that we actually
spend a little time together instead of
like giving each other respect through
like hallways at four different events a
year let's have a real dinner we should
have like one time I want to I'm excited
I'm really excited bout what you said
last night - I'm gonna sunshine I'm
gonna send my system message right now
take care of see that would that would
be that would make sense a player yeah
I'm gonna kill bonad
Yahoo proposed to put up around broke a
man through the mouth up right
everything's going
I forgot that's amazing that's the
highlight of the whole [ __ ] trip
right there dude how are you good good
to see you
how you doing really good man good sup
my man so hurry how you feel so you guys
don't give me I will that's gonna be the
best part I need to go I need to go
viral we're gonna zoom in on his toes
yeah you playing we should have looked
actually you know what
that's a was the first time I played
good intro can you text Tyler and say
new rule I mean dead serious CES South
by Kansas basketball game you will know
that yes and then we'll gather as Ryan
likes to shoot from the outside hey I
see you show me one you show me with no
we should start 100 that'd be fun that's
a real thing you don't appreciate
stephannie chiffons following bombing
Stefan can play a little he'll go like 1
for 13 from the field but oh that's a
great idea just like you guys have that
party less than like that's which that'd
be fun it'll become a whole thing and
you'll bring LeBron you know bring Chris
bright one every time were together for
one of these and then if God forbid I
score on dream I will just play it on
leap and also show for life oh my god
he's the best all right done Rick you
know what's crazy that people still for
some reason haven't figured it out this
isn't Bravo this is an MTV you're fully
in control like you like you don't like
me like practice make the first episode
it's good enough you put it up plus the
other thing is I actually was just
saying this to Pitman who Ryan used to
work with um when there's that much
volume you're not crippled by you know
we just did an interview together
sometimes it's one clip what I went
crazy and compared Twitter to Ricky
Rubio
you know like that's
moment you haven't seen that yet the
comp was that Twitter lost its way
because it didn't innovate for five
years
just like Ricky Rubio didn't develop a
shot and then I got a little crazy and
said if Rick Ricky Rubio wasn't was
working on his jump shot during the
summer instead of going to Ibiza and
banging chicks he would have won and so
it became this whole thing like Twitter
was banging chicks that's what it became
we won't rule number one nothing matters
like night if you really take a step
back
99% of [ __ ] doesn't matter and how do
you outsource so for example I produce
more content than anybody it's just that
I figured out at a macro all right I'll
just make them follow me everything's
being collected everything's being
edited now I do have to take time to
watch it you know like sometimes there's
a subtlety so there's a little
allocation but it's also like you know
how this is and listen you didn't build
a business by accident this I know is
important at this moment that's right
listen I think especially the truth of
your story is so [ __ ] real I'm so
excited about that brand part but in the
short term the one thing we've
consistently done for a couple of small
small pharma companies out of Philly and
things that make sure I know we can sell
at Walmart and Target I'm very confident
so I'm excited I think we will hold our
[ __ ] own I look cute but we do need a
lot of markets in this business oh [ __ ]
I'm so glad I get to see you you look
ridiculous where are you sleeping I love
it in where you going what are you gonna
we're gonna someone take a picture of
this
I just you did look at these cool kids
so what's up sup bro who's gonna win the
NBA Finals I have no idea because I know
it's wildcard weekend no one gives a
[ __ ] about em you you took me off before
I could say you're the only person who
doesn't give a [ __ ] cuz the Jets are
true I'm not your little scooter you
know I'm not I'm gonna watch I'm gonna
watch
can see how's it going good yeah I love
you Sheila
no it's that's not the case and I could
be seven people Claude we're not going
to we're not we're not pant we're not
pandering this everything in everything
in my life is on the record and that's
that like we're running a business we're
running a business Claude I mean we're
running a business you know like it's
like no I'm not saying it to you I'm
saying it to the world like what do you
think is happening solar waters but it's
really like I'm not alone I'm shouting
out the hustle gang of each and every
song my song came and gone I wish them
all the best
I hope you find another home and maybe
you can press these don't be sensitive
the birds I guess you took the fence
cause a changing room what was it's kind
of hard to stress over and
test a overload and they tried a best to
get over the trial a lo messes on faking
than a [ __ ] wearing Lee
press-ons don't you believe
get the step off they say family even
worse they keep the stress on and since
we on my first day
you can keep your dress on gentlemen the
Sun but on this song got my mess on no
respect for what I'm being my bucket
Jessa I'm amongst winners it's hustle
gang a nothing we've the car for dinner
you are [ __ ] selfish the meeting
place
[Music]
where are you
yeah we do
nah you can't stop how we work dude
we're sick dog you guys live in
commercials we in a win in this circle
yeah it was so fun to run into the team
love it yeah
there laughter on what a weird yeah we
in a win in this circle
welcome to winner's circle
been famous I was hot before the Sun
grows taking shots were higher getting
the murals we celebrated more welcome to
hate and more this only adds to the
flushing volume and big store and stash
box right next to the iron through the
door losing is not an option
titles like you fighting in the world of
Watson bro is sick you can mention it
with other toxins before the [ __ ] I was
planning researching and flying knife or
with it we just buy in and stocks with
them options was born a blip hustle gang
so you know what I'm walking with
ownership please put in the toko for the
game to that [ __ ] bleed fill your fans
thieves you and your mass lead we've
been blessed you ain't even got to say
it sleep I'm amongst winners it's hustle
gang enough it we eat the car for dinner
you are [ __ ] service the meter one
second
they'll be talking tough and we in the
[ __ ] muffin with me so good
the neighborhood's India smachim an
official now I wish you would try to
copy they find us in the woods
[Music]
we say
Cooper shows we in turn in a circle yeah
we in the winning a circle circle
welcome to winner's circle welcome to
winner's circle in a circle